I have to go there briefly
just to get your kind of thoughts in the
long-term future of robotics
there's been discussions on the GPT side
on the large language model side of
whether there's Consciousness inside
these language models
and I think there's fear but I think
there's also excitement or at least the
wide world of opportunity and
possibility in embodied robots having
something like
let's start with emotion
uh love towards other human beings
and uh perhaps the display real or fake
of consciousness
is this something you think about in
terms of long long term future because
as you as we've talked about people do
anthropomorphize these robots uh it's
difficult not to project some level of I
use the word sentience some level of
sovereignty identity all the things we
think is human that's what
anthropomorphization is as we project
humanness onto mobile especially legged
robots
um is that something almost from a
science fiction perspective you think
about or do you try to avoid ever
you try to avoid the topic of
Consciousness altogether
I'm certainly not an expert in it and I
don't spend a lot of time thinking about
this right
um and I do think it's fairly remote for
the machines that that we're dealing
with
um
our robots you're right the people
Anthem warfies they they read into the
robot's intelligence and emotion that
isn't there because they see physical
gestures
that are similar to things they might
even see in people or animals
um I don't know much about how these
large language models really work I I
believe it's a kind of statistical
averaging of the most common responses
you know to a series of words right it's
it's sort of um
a very elaborate uh word completion
um and I'm dubious that that has
anything to do with consciousness
um and I I even wonder if that model of
sort of simulating Consciousness by
stringing words together that are
statistically associated with one
another
um whether or not that kind of knowledge
if you want to call that knowledge
um would be the kind of knowledge that
allowed a sentient being to
grow or evolve it feels to me like
there's there's something about
truth or emotions
that's just a very different kind of
knowledge that is that is absolute like
a the interesting thing about truth is
it's absolute and it doesn't matter how
frequently it's represented in the world
wide web it
if you know it to be true it can only be
it may only be there once but by God
that's true
and I think emotions are a little bit
like that too you know something you
know and
and I just think that's a different kind
of knowledge than the way these large
language models uh derive sort of
simulated it does seem that intelligence
things that are true
um very well might be statistically well
represented on the on the internet
because the internet is made up of
humans
so I tend to suspect that large language
models are going to be able to simulate
Consciousness very effectively now I
actually believe that current gpt4 when
fine-tuned correctly be able to do just
that and that's going to be a lot of
very complicated ethical questions that
have to be dealt with that have nothing
to do with robotics they have and
everything to do with there needs to be
some process of
labeling I think what is true
because because there is also
disinformation available on the web and
these models are going to consider that
kind of information as well
and again you can't average something
that's true and something that's untrue
and get something that's moderately true
it's either right or it's wrong and so
how how is that process and and this is
obviously something that
the purveyors of these buyers and chat
gbt that I'm sure this is what they're
working on well if you interact on some
controversial topics with these models
they're actually refreshingly nuanced
they present because there's you realize
there's no one truth you know uh what
caused
the war in Ukraine right any
geopolitical conflict you could ask any
kind of question especially the ones
that are politically uh a tense divisive
and so on GPT is very good at presenting
here's the like here's the it presents
the different hypotheses it presents
calmly the the amount of evidence for
each one it's very it's really
refreshing it makes you realize that
truth is nuanced and it does that well
and I think with consciousness
it would very uh accurately say Well it
sure as hell feels like I'm one of you
humans but where's my body I don't
understand like you're going to be
confused the cool thing about GPT
is it seems to be easily confused in the
way we are like you wake up in a new
room and you ask where am I it seems to
be able to do that extremely well it'll
it'll tell you one thing like a fact
about when a war started and when you
correct it say well this isn't that's
not consistent it'll be confused it'd be
yeah you're right
it'll have that same element childlike
element with humility of trying to
figure out its way in the world and I
think
that's a really tricky area to uh to
sort of figure out with us humans of
what we want
um to allow AI systems to say to us
because then if there's elements of
sentience that are being on display you
can then start to manipulate human
emotion all that kind of stuff but I
think
that's that's something that's a really
serious and aggressive discussion that
needs to be had on the software side
um I think again embodiment uh
Robotics are actually saving us from the
arbitrary scaling of software systems
versus uh creating more problems but
that said I I really believe in the that
connection between human and robot
there's magic there
and I think uh there's also I think a
lot of money to be made there and Boston
Dynamics is leading the world in
um the most elegant movement
done by robots
so I I can't wait thank you to uh what
maybe other people that built on top of
uh Boston Dynamics robots or boss or
Boston Dynamics by itself